but you did interview the wolf of wall
street jordan belford and he said
he thinks it's a he's seen this
before yeah but also
i also interviewed it sounds like you're
not a big fan of them i'm not for wall
street i'm not why is this scumbag
really yeah tell me why i think uh if
you look at his net worth his net worth
is
minus a hundred million dollars okay
okay
so he's like minus a hundred million
dollars yeah
so i think people are fascinated him for
one reason one reason only
leonardo frickin dicaprio yeah okay that
guy should be
kissing leonardo dicaprio's ass every
single date of the week
he basically posterized them as being
the man well
in in reality he was a world-class
scumbag he ripped people off
and now he's capitalizing on his
instagram
sensationalized stuff that he's doing
it's the wolf's den the wolf of wall
street
and kind of like what you said if i
thought that he was a cool guy no one
remember that
i'm coming out and saying that i think
jordan belfort the wolf of wall street
is a first-rate scumbag you know when
you look at the movie the cocaine just
the womanizing all that stuff but you
know what it is shows you the power of
leo because remember he did that movie
catchy if he can
that the guy that was uh escaping the
fbi for years and years
i mean what a talented actor to make you
root for somebody like that
and i've i've actually met that guy
frank abagnale he's a real guy
he's i love it he gave me his cell phone
he's like call me anytime man i'm like
dude i just met you
he's like give me a call i'll i'm open
to anything yeah frank
frank frank at mcnally and i we're guys
we're guys he's so easy so maybe you
ought to interview jordan belfast i
would like to
talk to him he lives in manhattan beach
i could go look him up let's find him i
i don't think give us your thoughts on
jordan bufford i think i think he's
still using drugs hardcore
yeah i think jordan belfort lived a life
that for most 21 year old men
would dream about living for that two
three four five year run that he said
he was that young he was no no
what i'm trying to say is he has lived
the life of a thousand men combined in a
span of
five years sure the stuff that he did
just ridiculous out of control stuff
that this guy did
and eagle out of oh yeah oh he doesn't
deny that part i don't think he's just
there denying any of that stuff that's
taking place on what he did
and uh there's a community that can't
stand him and there's a community that
can't stand other people online that are
sales guys as well
who like his style more because he's
more uh uh
he's a more experienced sales guy and
how he is i've sat with him multiple
times
we spent some time together and every
time i've been around him
it's been respectable it's been it's
been um you know solid interaction that
he and i have had and he's actually
pretty smart guy
he's not a dummy he is actually a very
very smart guy
if you process his brain this guy was
going to be a doctor if you probably
look at his process and i have process
issues this guy was going to be a doctor
you know he was coming from a very good
family and all of a sudden he got caught
up in this whole
penny uh stock thing and found a way to
really push the envelope and
went out of control and he hurt a lot of
people he's the first person to say i'll
say this
yeah i didn't call him an idiot i didn't
call him a first class
i didn't call him you know a complete
buffoon
i said he was a scumbag there's a lot of
people who are scumbags do you actually
know the definition of a scumbag
is that is that a segue to our hungarian
story do you actually know the
definition
no no you don't even pull it up don't
even pull it out don't don't do it
because it's the wrong image
it's i think it's like something you put
in a vagina to like clean out your uh
no no do you actually know what a
scumbag is i mean does anybody here know
what it is
are you being serious i don't know the
true definition of us
you will never look at the word the same
way again do you know what the word
scumbag means do you know what a scumbag
means do you know what it means
kai do you know what it okay it's a used
condom okay okay yeah there
so when you say that phrase to me for
the rest of your life you're not going
to like people calling anybody scumbags
jordan belford is a used condom
up shriveled up throw that
in the garbage
but i don't think he's an idiot it takes
it takes someone with brains
and balls and bravado to do what he did
no doubt
well he but he's a used condom he lived
the life like he knew he was getting
away with something that he shouldn't so
he lived day to day i see these people
in miami all the time
you know sonny plays shady people nevin
shapiro he was a
um booster uh complete
uh running a ponzi scheme the other guy
in fort lauderdale i know his lawyer
mark okay that sounds right yeah the
other guy
um was a fort lauder i've seen these
people they
you know it's all smoke and mirrors and
big time and parting and drugs but
behind the back
they are stealing your money save that
money yeah he he was actually
one decision away from being a
billionaire he he
he was what was that shoe company
something adams what was the company
called the
is it uh oh no it was the most what's
the shoe company
what's it's not skechers what's the shoe
company uh
people wear it all the time doc martens
not doc martin no no no
he was one move away from being a
billionaire what is the shoe company
called
reebok no it's not reebok kyle you're
looking it up or no
yeah steve madden there you go i said
absolutely yes yes yes yes yes
he was about to he was an owner of steve
madden steve madden he's wearing a steve
madden they go people worse things
to jail too yeah exactly yeah so he was
about to be a billionaire
and things caught up and next thing you
know they took a big hit so this guy was
a guy that probably
if he wouldn't have screwed up the way
he did he would have been a billionaire
people would have told us
you're gonna get caught the stories
about like you know how you hear the
stories about
richard branson right where his mother
said and i don't know if you guys have
read the book the
virgin book the red book i don't know if
you read i read the book and his mother
said when he was a kid he says son
you're either going to end up in jail or
you're going to be a very powerful man
one day
it's gonna be one of the two well you
know jordan belfort was one decision
away from being a billionaire or he went
to jail he chose
what happens with these super smart
people the madoffs of the world yeah but
but
but the point on when he and i talked
about if you ever watch my first
interview with him
i asked about you know where you got in
trouble he said
i thought i could push the envelope and
i just kept pushing it more
and more and more and i thought i could
keep going and then i didn't know my
limitations it was already too late and
boom he got caught in the rest you're
gonna get caught when you act like
you're gonna get caught eventually when
you do something like that
i had a guy that uh um uh one of our
competitors
kept uh saying stuff about me okay
trashing me the last few weeks
okay you know this guy's this let me
tell you this guys
and then all of a sudden yesterday a
story got exposed about him
and i get a call from a couple of people
saying yo yo one of your guys did this
i'm like wait a minute what are we
talking about here i don't know what
you're talking about here i never knew
the story you know until when until
yesterday
he talked so much trash till the trash
caught up to him and in his biggest
trash
it got exposed to everybody and when you
play that game you just got to be ready
because it's going to backfire on you as
well eventually
so it this this ended a back fart on him
and uh
it is what it is but i tell you you know
talking to jordan
you're gonna be entertained he's gonna
tell some crazy story he's got some
strong opinions
and the guy was one or two decisions
away from being a billionaire and if
anybody knows that i think he knows it
himself
uh on what happened and it would have
been legit yeah it would have been
legibilian
he would have been a legit billionaire